new job Turner joins us now because
Halloween is also coming early to the
bowel show Dancing with the Stars Val is
trouble you know tonight is the first
group dance of the season and vows on
Nick Carter's team so I stopped by
rehearsal to see what their scaring up
over there here's a hint Nancy
they're called this one is extra special
because you got a kala ween ah
team nightmares number puts a Halloween
twist on The Nightmare Before Christmas
most people like Christmas or
Valentine's Day like I'm just kind of a
weird creepy kind of guy I'd say Nick
digs Halloween the Backstreet Boys video
everybody is a horror classic and the
guys performed it at the balm on fashion
event last week the vast cosmic to miss
a rehearsal for this dance and you
actually didn't even make the first you
know I did the ball mine I was at the
Balmer fashion event which was great and
I was with the guys and it was an honor
so I had to go and I missed a rehearsal
day for it but I'm here and and we're
trying to make up for it it's been a
scramble for team nightmare and tonight
they say expect chill so what's gonna be
special about this dance it's gonna make
you beat the other team the song is
called this is Halloween mm-hmm the
other team has Ghostbusters which I love
and I passed up on the song for this one
because I had the choice on this
this is not about rainbows and ponies
this is this is about ghouls and goblins
and tricks and treats and so we're gonna
give it all oh yeah this is gonna be
good now the dates are just announced
from the Dancing with the Stars live
dance all night tour they are hitting 43
City starting December 15th and they
begin in Salt Lake City their shoes are
going to be worn through the shell thank
you very much